what's going on guys this is Rob and
what I wanted to do in this video is
have a discussion about the Infinity
Gauntlet or at least explain the
Infinity Gauntlet actual gauntlet to you
guys I mean I've got the main Infinity
Gauntlet story about that'd be kind of
cool to run over this so when it comes
to the Infinity Gauntlet in Marvel
Comics I mean I would say by and large
both the story and the object itself are
probably two of the most popular things
ever created in the history of comic
books but one of the the biggest
misconceptions people have is that the
Infinity Gauntlet glove had basically
been well I guess really the Infinity
Jim's had essentially been created like
during the Infinity Gauntlet story
that's not necessarily the case when it
comes to the infinity gems they appeared
in a lot of different stories I mean
well they really originated in like a
handful of stories like Marvel team-up
number 55 Marvel premiere number one
guys like bill Mantlo and like jim
Starlin they're the ones that really
helped to like create the Infinity
stones and bring them into Marvel Comics
in truth the main Infinity Gauntlet
story and the actual Infinity stones
themselves kind of being assembled onto
the gauntlet that was a story that was
around 20 years in the making but the
cool thing about it is this it within
the Marvel Universe in terms of like the
actual gauntlet that wasn't really that
was realized by Thanos until like the
the first time he died basically I mean
he I guess it's really the second
depending on how you look at it but it's
really all kind of prefaced by something
called the Thanos war
now the Thanos war that was a series of
events written really by jim Starlin
himself I mean he was they gotta kind of
based all that stuff and it really all
goes back to Iron Man number 55 when
Thanos first showed up from the time
that Thanos first appeared until the
time that Thanos gained the Infinity
stones for the first time the fan oohs
was you know this this whole famous war
thing it was him just kind of looking to
destroy everything that's really all it
was the first time he faced off against
the earth superheroes he was looking to
gather the Cosmic Cube the second time
it was when he discovered the existence
of the infinity gems but he didn't know
what the infinity gems were capable of
all he ended up doing the first time he
gathered the gems was basically
channeling all their power into a huge
synthetic stone and then flying around
the universe and the most inefficient
way possible and linking out all the
stars in existence Thanos is knowledge
and and really the first revelation of
the
James didn't actually come until really
it was like it was it was probably
Thanos quest really like a Silver Surfer
story the way this played out was that
when Thanos died after gathering
Infinity stones for the first time he
was in the realm of mistress death and
he discovered something called the
Infinity well and the Infinity well is
basically this artifact that if you ask
it a question the right way they will
give you the answer to anything you want
and Thanos had asked the question what's
the origin of the Infinity stones and
how powerful are they and so what the
Infinity ball did was spew the whole
origin now something to bear in mind
here when it comes to the origin of the
Infinity stones this origin you know the
order of the universe has been retold
over and over and over and over again so
you can take it for what it's worth it's
not an absolute truth but what we're
told by Thanos really in the Thanos
quest story is that at the beginning of
all things in the universe there was
just the singular being and it was
lonely because there was nothing else
but it inside the universe and so what
it did is it took all the power that it
had and it channeled each property of
those powers into the infinity gems so
this beings power over reality was
channeled into the reality Jim its power
over time into the time Jim so on and so
forth and then dispersed the Jim's
across the cosmos they essentially just
kind of sat unused and unknown for eons
and eons and eons until various people
began to discover them and use them for
their own purposes not knowing the full
power of the infinity gems from there
Thanos had actually approached mistress
death and said give me the ability like
like resurrect me send me back to back
to the universe you know I can assemble
the Infinity Gauntlet and I can achieve
basically killing everything in
existence and appease you and make you
happy and so on and so forth mistress
death did that and that led into a story
called Fanus quest where he basically
travels around the cosmos and starts
gathering the Infinity stones everywhere
you can find them now from there but one
that one of the things that I
misunderstood for a long time is I
always believed that Thanos quest led
directly into Infinity Gauntlet it
actually doesn't there's a Silver Surfer
story that segues in between and I want
to say it was a story jim Starlin was
writing in the late I'll probably around
1990 maybe the late 1980s and it runs I
want to say it runs between like issues
51 and 52 up to like 59 or something
along those lines I could be wrong I
know that the the Serie I know Jim Solon
stopped writing it in the 50s I think
but essentially what happens is Silver
Surfer learns Stannis's gained
he's assembly the Infinity stones Silver
Surfer tries to stop him Thanos wrecks
him and send him flying across the
universe and he lands with a home of
Doctor Strange and says dude were so
screwed you have no idea how screwed we
are we're so screwed we're all gonna die
Thanos is gaining the infinity gems and
so that leads into the actual Infinity
Gauntlet story now for the most part
that story is probably one of the most
well known in all of comic books if
people don't necessarily know the events
that go on in it they know the name and
if they didn't know a whole lot about it
before they certainly know a lot now
because of the infinity war film that's
coming out so people have done a lot of
research on it I've got videos down in
the description that you're welcome to
go check out that run over the Infinity
Gauntlet story issue number 8 I don't
believe it's there yet I'm sorry apart
it's not there yeah I actually to
re-upload that which I'll do here in the
next day or so but the fact remains here
that following the events of Infinity
Gauntlet or at least for those two guys
who are unaware basically it's Stannis
with the Infinity Gauntlet just wrecking
everybody the cosmic entities and what's
left of the earth superheroes and
blinking out half a life in the universe
and so on and so forth this may be a
spoiler for infinity war I don't really
think it will be I think infinity war
will end with Thanos destroying half the
life in the universe but at the end of
the Infinity Gauntlet story nebula takes
the gauntlet from Thanos and the the
biggest issue with this the reason why
that's a problem is because Thanos was
just looking to gain absolute power
that's all it was he was just looking to
gain godhood nebula is as crazy as my
ex-girlfriend nobody knew what she was
gonna do like she was just nuts
like like people freaked out they were
like okay Thanos wanted godhood
who knows what nebula is gonna do she's
gonna turn the universe into some
twisted screwed up place and so because
of that you ended up having Thanos who
allied himself with Adam warlock and
what was left to the earth superheroes
and they showed up and they basically
confronted out confront a nebula it
really kind of boiled down to like smoke
and mirrors and shadow games and
ultimately what Adam warlock seizes the
gauntlet from nebula and then ends the
conflict fixes everything that Thanos
undid or at Thanos screwed up and then
the story ends so this goes into the
Infinity Gauntlet aftermath which is
warlock in the infinity watch Volume one
and the reason why this is an aftermath
is because immediately after Infinity
Gauntlet ends Adam warlock is taken
before the Living Tribunal and the
various cosmic entities and so on and so
forth and he was essentially put on
trial and the argument that's made here
is that Thanos sought to replace
eternity this
being of the universe Adam warlock seeks
to rule alongside eternity and that
creates an imbalance in the universe
that the linee tribunal must judge that
it has to preside over and give a ruling
for and so leading tribunal basically
says eternities rightful role is to be
the Supreme Being of the universe if
Adam warlock seeks to replace eternity
that's fun but Adam warlock cannot rule
alongside eternity and because Adam
warlock didn't look to didn't seek to
replace eternity ultimately the Living
Tribunal judged against Adam warlock
deactivated the Infinity Gauntlet and
then said now you have to disperse the
gems the god will never work in unison
but you have to assign the gems to other
people and so Adam warlock ultimately
created the Infinity watch now I think I
know if a nose was part of the infinity
watch I'm pretty sure Gamora moondragon
and pip Patrol were as well of course
Adam warlock and then I want to say
maybe there was one more I can trim off
the top my head but ultimately what this
group was designed to do was to
safeguard the Infinity stones that leads
directly into in the Infinity war
storyline which is starkly different
from the movie it's gonna be drastically
different from the movie the overall
gist of the infinity war story was that
this was this kind of came with its
revelation that when Adam warlock first
gained the Infinity Gauntlet he had
subconsciously purged himself of good
and evil
he had his evil hath in the form of the
Magus and he had his good half in the
form of the goddess the return of the
Magus basically saw like the infinity
war story progressing in such a way that
we saw all these doppelgangers of
various superheroes and villains and so
on and so forth that were created by the
dimension and manifestations at the
request of at the request of the Magus
if you don't know what the dimension of
manifestations and anthropomorphic is
doesn't matter not a huge deal and so
because of that what Magus also did was
travel around the universe and gather
all these cosmic I'm sorry cover on the
multiverse and gather all these
different cosmic cubes and that was
designed to serve as a distraction as a
ruse because then what the Magus did is
while everybody else was hunting and
fighting these doppelgangers and so on
the Magus was running around gathering
the Infinity stones and now during this
time Adam warlock had realize what was
going on and basically was a living
tribunal instead you have to reactivate
the Infinity Gauntlet in order for my
plan to work and so the living tribe you
don't get that basically reactivated the
Infinity Gauntlet
so it would always work whenever the
gems were brought together in eunice
this story ended with the revelation
that what Thanos had done is he had
actually replaced the real reality stone
with a fake one and so when the Magus
had gone to use the to use the Infinity
Gauntlet it didn't work completely he
didn't have all of its power
this allowed Adam warlock and the
various superheroes to slip in and then
essentially defeat the Magus story ends
from there it goes on into like the
goddess and infinity crusade doesn't
really have anything to do with the
Infinity Gauntlet for the most part at
least the story's not nearly as
significant but following infinity war
probably going forward for about another
let's see that was 1992-93 so going
forward from that point for about ten
years the Infinity Gauntlet was wasn't
really seen again I mean it appeared in
like flashbacks and it appeared in like
small stories here and there but for the
most part like having an actual story
arc unto itself that didn't happen until
the mid-2000s going up until 2010 with
the heroic age now in terms of like the
mid 2000s this was significant because
what this did is it basically gave us
the Illuminati now the Illuminati were
created by Brian Michael Bendis and it
was a genius idea in terms of what he
did what he did is he sat down and he
said okay so so like 20 stark I think it
was I want to say it was Tony Stark had
come to this realization that in the
early days of Marvel Comics of course
were there having been a story called
the kree-skrull war which is actually
what agents of shield is teasing the
season or maybe it'll be next season
where it happens any event that's the
big invasion that's coming as a Kree
scroll war because of what had happened
on the kree-skrull war had gotten
exceedingly close to earth close enough
that had almost destroyed the planet
this war between the Curia and the
scroll empires and so Tony Stark had
come to the realization that like
himself and Charles Xavier of the x-men
and Doctor Strange and Reed Richards of
the Fantastic Four and naming the
Submariner and you know these various
people had tidbits of information that
if they had shared it would have kept
the Kree school of war from getting as
close to Earth as it did and so Tony
Stark proposed that the the group
basically come together and form a kind
of secret society that would offer a
behind-the-scenes and nobody would know
who they were and this was the creation
of the Illuminati
now the first meeting place was in
Wakanda right light you know they they
show up in Black Panthers homeland
because no one can go there unless my
Panther invites them so it's the perfect
meeting place and black panther like
right off the bat is like do not do this
this is a terrible idea like this idea
is as terrible as Sony making Marvel
movie
do not do this like it'll fail it'll be
disastrous it'll end terribly light and
it did of the Illuminati and in the
worst way possible oh my god it was it
was Captain America doing like a like an
international manhunt for the Illuminati
that like they flew across the universe
trying to find the Illuminati was it was
insane you know what with that whole
story but the fact remains here in the
Illuminati essentially went forward as
this group that did like all these
different schemes and these different
things behind the scenes one of the
first things they did is they travel to
the scroll homeworld and they said look
you're free scroll war almost brought
like brought ruin to earth do not come
back if you come back we'll come back
here and we'll kill you up like we will
annihilate every last one of you the
scrolls took the Illuminati knocked them
out scan their body scan their DNA and
then sent them on their way with their
memories wife having no idea what
happened what ended up actually
happening is the scrolls analyzed the
genes of the Illuminati and then began
analyzing the genes of all of your
superheroes and that led into the secret
invasion storyline
there were things like the Illuminati
banishing the Incredible Hulk from
Planet Earth because he was deemed to be
too dangerous that led into Planet Hulk
which led into world war hulk basically
the idea was that the illuminati kept
screwing up over and over and over again
but with regards to our discussion here
but one of the big things that happen
with the illuminati is that Reed
Richards had basically sat down and said
okay so the infinity gems are insanely
powerful individually but when they're
united and they're brought together in
the the the Infinity Gauntlet is
reformed that person will be virtually
unstoppable and so there's only one
group who's capable of keeping the
infinity gems protected and never using
them and that of course is us it's the
most arrogant thing ever like we as the
Illuminati we've investigated ourselves
and we have found no wrongdoing like
it's the most arrogant thing that any
group could possibly do
but the Illuminati basically start
traveling around the universe almost
like dragon ball and basically gather
like all the infinity gems now the funny
thing about this is that when Reed
Richards goes to like reassemble the
Infinity Gauntlet because he's like what
we just seem to check and make sure that
it works The Watcher pops up and the
Watchers like dude you need to stop like
do not use the do not reassemble it do
not use it do not do any of that I know
what you're gonna do do not reassemble
the infinity gauntlet and we're Reed
Richards is like held
on reassembling the thing suddenly he
has a change of heart and he says yeah
you know what I shouldn't I shouldn't
reassemble this and then basically takes
the gyms puts him in like a secret bomb
I'm sorry hands them out to the
Illuminati and then that's it what we
end up finding out is that Charles
Xavier had actually messed with the mind
of Reed Richards and like like planted
the the idea that Reed Richards needs to
put the Infinity Gauntlet away and so it
was like damn like man Xavier is
powerful like he's a super powerful God
but what this does is this goes into the
heroic age now the heroic age was the
culmination of ten years of work done by
Marvel a little bit of history here in
the early 2000s really in the late 1990s
with Marvel's suffering from near
collapse in the huge comic bust of the
90s Marvel brought in a guy named Joe
Quesada who had basically held a company
alongside Jimmy Paul Muni called a venn
comics and they basically published a
bunch of the character as published
stories on characters that were that
were not going to sell comics but still
had a fanbase and so Marvel you know in
the early 2000 late night you know these
Marvel only cared about big names x-men
Fantastic Four Avengers and so on black
panther daredevil those guys Punisher
they weren't considered bankable names
they were popular but they weren't
really selling people knew who they were
but it didn't really sell any copies and
so event publishing basically wrote all
all the stories for that and that's
where you get Marvel Knights and so what
ended up happening is casada came in in
the early 2000s and basically cleaned
house so we got things like the mayor's
between Peter Parker Mary Jane Watson
wiped out during the events of one more
day the Avengers book was basically
canceled and then relaunched his New
Avengers there were a whole bunch of
things that went on house of M the
mutant population was reduced it was
insane but there were all these stories
that took place over the the 2000s that
were designed to get superhero comics
back to being superhero comics and
manageable and so the heroic age came
out of Dark Reign with his own Norman
Osborn took over the record took over as
director of shield disbanded it replace
it with hammer and then tried to conquer
the world because you know when you're a
bad guy that's what you do when you have
absolute control of like the Earth's
militaries and so because of that you
know following the defeat of Norman
Osborn people were like oh man we can't
do this again we have to go back to
being good guys and so on and so forth
and so the heroic age saw the relaunch
of The Avengers the relaunch of uncanny
x-men all these different things that
went on in the first story arc
of the heroic age of the the New
Avengers title a guy by the name of
Parker Robbins also known as the hood
had basically learned the Illuminati
were hiding the Infinity stones and so
what he did is he started traveling
around it was a crazy story it was stuff
like the Red Hulk got the Power Stone
like it was bonkers it was it was really
really cool but at the end of it all
Parker Robbins ends up ends up traveling
to the mind skin I want to say it's like
the astral plane
the montt whatever it is the games are
traveling to life - like the astral
plane basically we need to say it's that
and tries to capture the mind stone all
the earth superheroes like meet up there
and then Tony Stark and all the other
superheroes successfully defeat Parker
Robbins and then Tony Stark takes the
mind stone reassembles the Infinity
Gauntlet and Iron Man gets the Infinity
Gauntlet and so following that when the
whole thing is said and done Iron Man's
like okay we're gonna fix everything in
the Parker Robbins screwed up and then
we're gonna destroy the Infinity
Gauntlet and he was like ah it's gone
you know but in reality he had sent it
back to the headquarters of the
Illuminati and so what ends up happening
is the Illuminati dispersed the infinity
gems amongst themselves once more this
leads into Jonathan Hickman's Avengers
and New Avengers with the incursion
start happening right like you know the
universe is crashing into each other
because of what molecule man and Doctor
Doom did and so because of that the
infinity gems are brought together by
the Illuminati they're reassembled
Charles Xavier of course has been dead
since the Avengers vs. x-men so Captain
America basically takes its place and so
you have the Infinity stones that are
brought back together again the Infinity
Gauntlet is reassembled because the
Illuminati believe the Infinity Gauntlet
being so powerful can stop the
incursions from happening so when a
universe starts to make its way towards
the main Marvel Universe and the
impending crash within eight hours
begins
Captain America takes the gauntlet and
tries to push the universe away
ultimately it fails and all the infinity
gems except for the time Jim are totally
destroyed they shatter in their entirety
the time Jim just vanishes just
disappears into the time stream
eventually comes back and then whisked
Captain America like fifty thousand
years of the future isn't like that but
the fact remains like that's that's
basically the end of the Infinity
Gauntlet as far as it stands right now
in Marvel Comics the Infinity Gauntlet
exists now there's actually a story
called infinity countdown which is
leading to the reformation of the
gauntlet and all the infinity gems
coming together and so on and so forth
it's basically like Thanos quest on a
grander scale is really all it is so
it's a sense
just a rehash story told a different way
but the fact remains like that's kind of
where we stand right now somebody out
there is reassembling the gems it's a
race to reassemble the gauntlet and then
who knows what'll happen from there but
nonetheless hopefully this helped you
guys out for those guys who were new to
to Marvel Comics those of you guys who
weren't really familiar with the
Infinity Gauntlet as a concept as an
idea or the object hopefully that helps
and get you guys sorted out and the very
least you go forward into the infinity
war film having a pretty good idea of
what to expect especially what's gonna
happen in that movie is it's going to be
like the worst case scenario like you're
gonna walk out of that believing
everything's hopeless for earth
superheroes because what chance to what
chance does Captain America stand
against the might of a god so it's gonna
be kind of cool it's gonna be it's gonna
be pretty awesome but we don't being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end if you are new here to come
this explain make sure you guys have the
sub button to become part of the robb
core if you guys enjoy the video make
sure you drop a like and it will catch
you all later peace